okay let's go we're white against a 1744 and obviously as is our custom we play e4
we'll dedicate this to chigorin for those watching on youtube i um just spent a while
going in a little chess history tangent and talking about mikhail chigorin one of the top
players of the 19th century world champion contender one of the strongest tactical
players of his day okay we're facing the sicilian once again we play the alapin and the alapin by
the way himself was probably top 20 in the world uh not close to a world champion but
also lived in the same time i think as chigorin and steinitz and was a contemporary
and you know contributed tremendously to opening theory he was mostly an opening
theoretician i think from lithuania originally but also a strong player okay so knight c6 is one
of the most common responses to the alapin but it is already believe it or not a serious inaccuracy
i wouldn't go so far as to call it a mistake if black follows up correctly then black can
essentially turn this into a viable system but if black makes one more inaccuracy things can
actually get disastrously bad within five six moves now our response to knight c6 is obvious
why do we play c3 well we play that to prepare d4 knight c6 doesn't actually prevent d4 we have
enough defenders on that square so we start by grabbing control of the center and in short the
reason that the knight on c6 is often misplaced in these lines is is actually quite simple first of
all we recapture with a pawn we're essentially threatening to push this pawn down at d5 and
without the support of a pawn shell this is why as i've explained before it's a bad idea to bring
your pieces out without moving your pawns because then your pawns start tossing those pieces around
and the pieces just don't have any footholds in the center and ultimately could even get trapped
or driven back to their initial squares which could be a disaster given the extent of our
central control so for instance after d5 i know it's black to move but just for the sake of
illustration d5 95 right we follow up with f4 and there you kind of see that the knight on e5 has to
move all the way back to g6 and it's going to be tremendously hard for black in those resulting
positions to get the other pieces out a big mistake here would be to play knight f6 this
would actually throw oil onto the fire because in that line after d5 95 f4 knight g6 we actually
play e5 and the only square that the knight on f6 will have is to go back to g8 because both g4 and
h5 are covered by white's queen good example of quote-unquote violating opening principles and
moving only your pawns but here it's obviously justified because we're tossing black's pieces
around we're playing with tempo so already a very dangerous situation for black i had an eight move
game that i played when i was 1800 that i'll show quickly after this game in that game my opponent
played e6 in this position the best move theoretically is d5 black needs to counter
strike in the center but after d5 we get a very very theoretical continuation in which black can
once again lose and flame out in just a couple of moves so according to the engine d5 is strongest
here but black needs to know exactly what to do in the resulting position to avoid getting you know
smashed in the center and driven out of the gym yeah after d5 we take so in short we either play
our own pawn to d5 grabbing more control of the center and chasing the knight away
okay the second approach is just to develop our pieces knight c3 and knight f3 which
is always a decent alternative and if black plays d5 then we will take on d5 and a common instinct
for players is of course to meet d5 with e5 but who can explain positionally and you know again
if you're watching on youtube something you can figure out while our opponent is thinking okay d5
on the board very nice why is e5 not accurate here because you might especially if you play
the advanced french you might say well this is just like an advanced french but there is a key
difference in the french the black pawn is already on e6 so black has what we call the french bishop
the light squared bishop which always experiences problems after e5 here black gets essentially a
very very good french or a good caracon getting the bishop out to f5 and only then locking up
the center with e6 so you don't want to get into a french where you've let the light squared bishop
out that's an inferior version it's not losing for white or anything like that but it doesn't
pose serious problems so long story short we take on d5 and we transpose into a line that could also
be reached with a different move order in fact it normally is reached with the move order d5 here
move to trade d4 trade and knight c6 so you can follow in your head that line and you will see
that the same position is reached a very common mistake for inexperienced players to play knight c3
right the instinct to attack the queen unfortunately this is not a scandi and you have to notice that
the d4 pawn is hanging it's got two attackers on it and only one defender so we first and foremost
need to protect that pawn while developing our other knight knight f3 and if you stumble into
this opening without theoretical knowledge this should actually look very scary especially if
black puts the bishop on g4 because it may seem that we have absolutely no chance of keeping the
pawn on d4 alive and what's interesting is that after bishop g4 we actually sacrifice that pawn
but we do it strategically and develop a massive initiative i'll show you some really really cool
resulting lines and maybe we'll even get them on the board so after bishop g4 knight c3 is the move
trying to force the queen out of the center and conceptually the one big thing to know here
is that if the queen is driven back from d5 we can ourselves then advance the pawn to d5 and that can
lead immediately to catastrophic consequences because black is so underdeveloped on the king
side that if we're able to push our pawn to d5 and drive the knight back there's a check on b5
there's a queen check on a4 and that could all be totally deadly if black is not very cautious
yeah this is already an iqp structure iqp a common abbreviation for isolated queen pawn
isolated meaning that there are no neighboring pawns um no c pawn no e pawn both of those
pawns have been traded or transformed the c pawn still exists it's just now the d pawn right this
originally was the pawn that sat on c3 yeah so black has like three major continuations here
that are considered legitimate according to theory bishop g4 is very popular but to my knowledge a
bad move objectively and if white responds accurately black already gets in serious
trouble but you basically have to know exactly what to do here with white as far as i know the
objectively best continuation the one that reduces the damage is actually the very modest move e6
which is not a move a lot of people want to play because it closes down the bishop but
the move e6 lends another support to the d5 square so that after we bring our knight out and the queen
moves back the move d5 doesn't come with as much effect black can just take it okay bishop g4
played and i love that we're getting this because this is a super important line and if you're an
alapin player you're going to get this a lot in online play and you're going to get this in over
the board play as well so again i like to approach this from the perspective of someone who hasn't
seen this position before because that gives you insight into what your intuition is likely to be
and that gives you a better chance to remember counter-intuitive moves right when you know what
the intuitive move is and you know that it's wrong you can make a memory marker in that regard so to
me there's a pin on the knight and there's an instinct i think for a lot of people to play
bishop b2 especially because if black takes on f3 and takes on d4 he loses the queen because bishop
takes c6 is check eliminating the defender i'll show all of this on the board after the game
the issue with bishop e2 isn't that it's wrong tactically it's that it's slow and it allows black
to bring the pawn out to e6 and prepare himself for the inevitable knight c3 so we need to cut
out the middleman here and we need to go directly for the queen while black still has not gone e6
we need to play knight c3 straight away now if you look carefully at this move it may seem that
black has a very compelling response and as a hint this response does not involve moving the queen
if black moves the queen he's busted and we already know what to do we're going to push d5
essentially automatically and black can lose there in like another three moves there is this weird
move bishop takes knight right and it leads to a bunch of chaos if we take the queen then black
takes our queen and if we recapture the bishop with our king then not only have we lost our
castling rights but that knight on d5 can be targeted with long castles the knight is hanging
the pawn on d4 is surely going to be lost there and that doesn't seem appetizing in the least
now you could say but wait a second after bishop takes f3 knight takes queen bishop takes queen
we don't have to recapture the bishop we can give a fork on c7 but that is also problematic
because if you extend the line king d8 knight takes a8 you don't even need to calculate any
further to understand that that position is not all roses for white because the knight on a8
isn't really getting out and if black is able to track that knight down and win it then black will
then black will have two pieces for the rook which given the fact that the rooks are still
you know on their initial spots is not a rosy option for white so in response to bishop takes
f3 this is one of the lines you have to memorize you simply have to memorize it you also have to
understand it but if you want to be a good elephant player this is one of the lines you
should start with and i will it's a shame that our opponent didn't take on f3 but that's okay
it remains behind the scenes and it will await us in our post-game analysis this is just as
important to know how to refute queen to a5 okay so as already indicated our instinct here and we
just need to double check that this move is still good but i still think it is is to play d5 right
why why the urgency to push the pawn because if we allow black to play e6 then d5 loses a lot of
its a lot a lot of its effect because it just allows black to trade on d5 and we are unable
to kick the knight out of c6 why is it important to kick the knight out of c6 well first of all
because it is nowhere good to go and second of all because once the knight moves away from c6
we have an incredibly nasty check on b5 that could actually force the king to move to d8 and
that's a complete disaster especially with the king side entirely undeveloped so definitely we
go d5 here and we do that without a second thought i think black can probably worm his way out of
this and avoid an immediate disaster with some computer play but practically speaking black's
position is already borderline lost and these are bold words but hopefully i can back that up with
the course of the game yeah so some of you are rightly noticing that black does not have to
move the knight away and black can make this very sneaky move long castle with the idea of pinning
the deep on to the queen and d takes c6 would be very unwise because we lose the queen with check
but after long castle it's important to note two things the first is that the black king on c8
is incredibly vulnerable not because castling long is inherently dangerous although it is
but because the c file is open and not only is it open it's very easy for us to get a rook to c1
and everybody should understand why getting a rook to c1 would be so dangerous to black right
the rook has a direct line of fire to the king and the king might simply not make it all the way into
the corner and even if it does there are other horrors that await the king on a8 i'll show you
a good illustration of this after the game one of my earliest allop and wins and sort of fondest
memories a game from the the under 10 world youth in 2005 against a player who is now a very strong
gm himself so castle king's queen side is is not scary and neither is rook to d8 rook to d8
temporarily defends the knight but we could very easily reinforce renew the threat of d takes c6
we can do that in many different ways we can simply move the queen out of the pin we can go queen b3
we can also block the pin with a move like bishop d2 which is also very productive because it sets
up our own x-ray against the queen so bad news here for black and i think our opponent recognizes
it takes on f3 okay so here let's try to play as precisely as possible let's try to go for the kill
quickly without allowing any additional options so again the intuitive response is queen takes f3
unless there is a good reason you don't want to damage your kingside pawn structure not that
we're afraid to get checkmated but you know if queen takes f3 is good then we should play it
now does queen takes f3 have any downsides well as i see it it has only one sort of downside that
we need to reckon with which is that queen takes f3 allows the knight to jump into the center with
tempo with either 94 or 95 and 94 might seem like the scarier move to you because the knight also
threatens to travel onward to c2 but let's look concretely queen takes f3 94 is not actually
dangerous at all because the queen can centralize to e4 preventing knight c2 because it covers the
square and simultaneously attacking the knight the knight actually doesn't have anywhere to go
because it's completely restricted by the pawn on d5 queen takes f3 95 might actually be a more
resilient move for black but similarly it's not dangerous it hits our queen yes but we could move
our queen up to f5 or even play the same move queen e4 so the upside of playing gf here and
spoiler alert i think either move is possible and i'm actually not sure which one is better
gf is cool because after the knight moves the knight has nowhere to go with tempo so after the
knight moves let's say to the same e5 square we could bring our bishop out with check and virtually
force the king to move into the center which is a total disaster or the knight would have to block
similarly looks very very ugly so i like g takes f3 i like queen takes f3 queen takes f3 is the more
positionally sound move the move that you would play if you wanted to play with an abundance of
caution i'm actually not sure i'll think about this for like a couple moments gf 95 you could
also go queen b3 there attacking b7 both options look incredibly juicy this is a very good problem
to have but i do have a gut feeling i have a gut feeling and i can't fully explain it my gut feeling
is that queen takes f3 is better and and it's just it's just an intuitive sense and there are
there is like one consideration that justifies that which i'll talk about after the game but
i don't want to delve too deeply into it okay so 95 is the instant response by our opponent
and now okay two options that i like queen e4 and queen to f5 both moves hit the knight and both
moves bring the queen to a more active spot now queen f5 i think i like more for one main reason
after queen to e4 the knight let's say drops back to d7 and that queen on e4 is going to be
vulnerable to knight g to f6 and the way that we screw this up with white is we allow black to get
his entire kingside out quickly and if that happens and black is able to castle kingside
which sounds incredibly distant but it's not actually that many moves away we can't fall
asleep here because how many moves does black need one two three and on the fourth black is
already ready to castle that's not forever so we don't want to give black tempo moves for no reason
bishop b5 would be a very instructive mistake because of queen takes b5
desperado knight takes b5 knight takes f3 and importantly that's a check right we can't go
knight c7 there because our king is in check we have to recapture the knight and the worst thing
we could do here is allow a queen trade also very good is to play queen g3 lovely move as well queen
g3 uh is is fantastic too because it keeps the queen out of the weeds and it keeps it out of the
way of white's pieces and also out of the way of black's pieces right the queen on g3 can basically
not be attacked at all so let me think about this again for just a second queen g3 versus queen f5
is what i'm trying to decide between and there's some calculation to do there
queen f5 there there there there's a cool idea there that i'm wrestling with not sure how strong
it is not strong not sure how strong it is so there there there there d6 gosh that looks very
juicy as well hmm yeah in a classical game i'd probably go queen g3 but i'm agonizing i really
want to play this accurately because i want to finish the game before move 20 if possible
hmm okay let's adhere to a rule that i have shared before in previous speedruns which
originally comes from yasser sarah one yeah yes and yasser introduced this to me like many years
ago when he talked about using the queen as a supporting actress that's like the terminology
that he used and i have a chess.com article based on that the idea is simple right when we think of
how our queen should participate in an attack we often think that the queen should be on the
front lines right it should be right in your opponent's grill but the queen is a lot it's
the ultimate long-range piece so oftentimes it might be a bit counterintuitive but keeping the
queen in the shadows directing the attack from a distance can often be a lot more effective
simply because the queen is such a valuable piece that you want to keep your main war general you
know behind safe lines to avoid a situation where the queen starts stumbling around and allowing
tempo moves well queen g3 to that end seems like a perfect spot for the queen because it's doing a
lot of stuff stacking the knight it's pressuring g7 it's potentially can infiltrate to c7 if the
black queen moves obviously it's also discouraging black from castling queenside but it's essentially
as i said earlier unattackable whereas on f5 the queen may seem to be doing more but it is very
much attackable right it might walk into g6 and again i don't want to give like any developmental
tempo moves so hopefully that the general logic makes sense there are some specific lines i looked
at there um which i'll which i'll share afterward 97 okay so it would be very very nice if we could
play knight to b5 because 97 would be very hard to stop unfortunately that's illegal and in general
this pin is annoying me the queen on a5 is black's only good piece and it i think is sensible to take
the sting out of it so as as tempted as some people may be by bishop b5 which i know is on
the tip of some people's tongue great move by the way nothing wrong with it but bishop b5 black
develops the knight to f6 and just the pin against the knight alone isn't going to win us the game
it's hard to pressure that d7 knight another time so let's make a more modest looking move bishop to
d2 but i think this really allows us to fulfill the potential of our pieces it threatens knight b5
that's the direct threat attacking the queen discovered attack and the knight c7 is unstoppable
so black already has to do something against that threat probably move the queen back which gives
us another tempo that we can use either to play bishop b5 or maybe to still play knight b5 which
is still very dangerous even if it doesn't attack the queen but depending on what white does black
does will will decide on a subsequent course of action now i'm positive if you're following the
game with an engine that i'm not playing perfectly i have no doubt about that and it's hard to play
perfectly in a position where you've got like five or six tempting options on each move you shouldn't
expect yourself to play perfectly you should expect yourself to make reasonable moves which
almost always will lead to a positive conclusion even if you don't play perfectly this was a genius
move by our opponent that i completely missed this is a incredible idea that our opponent just
uncovered and the idea is to meet knight b5 with queen takes bishop check king takes queen and 94
check picks up the white queen and as a result attacks the rook on h1 which will force us to
recapture on g3 and again we are trying to avoid the end game like a plague so this is the importance
of double checking that your opponent's move doesn't in fact prevent your main idea all right
at this level 1700 plus most of the time people are going to see one move threats so your instinct
should always be to double check now let's not panic right you see that it's easy to panic
let's root out the source of the problem the source of the problem is this e4 square so can
we defend that square but not a move like f3 which doesn't do anything else can we develop a piece
and protect that square i like the simple move bishop d3 yeah it gets the bishop out
and it reinforces the threat of knight b5 and in general the way that we're playing is such that
we're preparing for the worst case scenario right you shouldn't sacrifice pieces without need you
shouldn't do crazy stuff unless you need to and the way we're playing like even if the worst case
scenario comes to pass and black finds some way to castle kingside guess what it's really not the
end of the world we still have the bishop pair we still have a strong pawn in the center that
we'll be able to defend and black still has problems with coordinating their pieces so
we're trying to win the game quickly but we're also making moves that are independently good
and those are the types of moves you should strive for to avoid you know crashing and burning in a
winning position sometimes you have to go for the sack and sometimes you have to go for the
risky continuation but here we've got the luxury of making these types of moves they're not always
the you know gonna win you the beauty prize but they're gonna win you a lot of games yeah black
can take d5 but i don't care about that we're just gonna castle we're just gonna keep developing and
we're gonna eat the king alive eventually once the rook comes into the open file once the rook
comes to e1 that king on e8 is just gonna be complete and utter toast also what i like is
that knight takes d5 opens up the d file and you could say well how does that matter at all well
it doesn't on the next move but it will in three moves because after we castle we could bring the
a rook over to d1 what's on the d file well that knight on d7 that we actually started with that
was our initial concept that knight later on could be just victimized massacred with a move like
bishop b5 and combined with a rook on d1 you could kind of envision a scenario where the pressure
against the knight becomes instantly unbearable now another thing that i kind of keep repeating
like a broken record is that when you play in this way and you put pressure from the very
first moves even if objective even if a computer could survive for another 50 moves and turn the
game around notice what's happening he's taking loads of time on every move and almost certainly
a blunder is going to come to to expedite the process in the next couple of moves i think we
are winning objectively but likely our opponent's going to help us out just because the pressure is
so unbearable what should black do here i think black is toast queen b6 so patience is the order
of the day and i think i think knight b5 is very very tempting that was our initial idea but it no
longer comes with tempo no longer attacks the queen and so knight b5 black can meet perhaps
with knight takes d5 which i don't really see the need to allow so what is a good patient
simple move that we could play relatively fast keeps all of our advantages and just prepares
you know major major problems on the even just castle castle kingside i think some of you might
be wondering if we can castle queenside but again no need no need to be fancy that king on c1
because of the semi-open c file two can play at that game why allow black
counter play and activity along the c file castle kingside is uh you know much more prudent here
here talk that king away and now the e file is a direct line of access against the black king and
we have the machinery to exploit it i'm expecting g6 and there we will have to be very accurate
because black will be only two moves away from castling but i think that gives us just enough
time to generate threats before the king is able to escape no long castle for white is fine white's
not going to get checkmated there it's just annoying a6 okay the problem is our opponent
is trying to cover things with a band-aid but like the whole you know the whole world is exploding
here for black you know he shot down one balloon but there's others so what do we do now now that
we can't go in ip5 we can try to play like tall we can try to play like tall and go d6
and it's a it's a tempting move because if you can open the e file that looks like absolute death
to the black king the issue is that after d6 black can meet that with e6 a move that's very
commonly overlooked right actually pushing the pawn past your pawn and what might end up happening
is that we actually lose the d6 pawn and we still don't get to open the e file again we need to play
we need to play it very simple here the simple moves are by far the strongest in these types of
overwhelming positions you seem to accumulate and accumulate and eventually you need to sense
the moment when you know the sort of slow moves allow you to find some sort of concrete combination
but right now we still have low hanging fruit that we can pick off and rook fe1 is just such
you know an example just putting the rook on the same file as our as the enemy king and preparing
to launch some shenanigans against the e7 pawn now by the way d6 is more tempting but still d6
we should not rush because of e6 something to really take away from this game right a very
common mistake d6 e6 and suddenly we've actually improved black's pawn shell okay queen takes b2
is obviously possible but you know pinching a dinosaur is how you should think of it
we really could not care less about a corner pawn yeah that attacks the bishop but these are just
one move threats that can be easily addressed we probably have some tactical win against queen
takes b2 maybe queen c7 is winning something like that but we wouldn't even have to do that we'll
talk after the game about it okay so this is where we really need to hunker down because we have two
moves we have three minutes on the clock so i'll have to speed up and we need to find some way to
prevent bishop g7 and castles kingside preferably without going crazy so let me think about this for
a minute because i don't i don't see it yet but i'm sure it'll it'll occur to us i have one idea
i have sort of a backup option i have a backup option but i want to find something really pretty
okay man i have a cool idea but it doesn't quite do the trick okay we could double on the e-file
but black will gladly give up the e7 pawn in order to castle that's not you know that's that's not how
our rome was built hmm there's a line that almost results in mate but again keyword being almost 94
knight takes c4 rookie for bishop b7 i'm genuinely calculating by the way i'm not trying to be you
know pretend that i'm looking and i've already found and i haven't found it yet i think we're
going to go for the backup option and the backup option might be the best move in the position so
let me play the move just because of the time and again if you're sort of feeling lost we'll talk
after the game more more deeply bishop to e3 hit the queen counterintuitive in its appearance
because we block the e-file but remember when you block a file with your own piece right you
are in control of your own pieces this is a frankfurt airport type move i'm trying to force
the queen onto a worse spot in the event of queen takes b2 we're going to put the bishop on d4 this
is ultimately likely the final destination for the bishop why d4 well because it's on the long
diagonal it's pressuring the knight and it's really adding strain uh to the position to black's
position but it really depends on where the queen goes the queen doesn't have a lot of squares
actually surprisingly that does not queen d6 maybe but then we can even play bishop f4
or queen back to d8 the king is fully boxed in knight h5 our opponent trying to be fancy
but ultimately i think this just loses the game on the spot and again and again i think this is
a theme of this game that's going to ultimately be a big takeaway when you're trying to win games
it's easy to walk into the impression that every attack is supposed to be beautiful and every
attack is culminated with a sacrifice and we probably could do that if we wanted to but we're
playing the speed run to win games efficiently and for me to show how to win games efficiently
and there's a very efficient win here first thing you have to calculate when both queens are hanging
there's a checklist first item on the checklist can we move our queen away with check thereby
winning the queen no right well we can play queen b8 but that doesn't help second thing can we
desperado our queen can we give our queen up for something and then take our opponent's queen no
we can take the pawn but that makes no sense our opponent just recaptures and ultimately we just
lose a piece third thing what happens if we actually take our opponent's queen and then try
to move that that piece away with tempo this is what we have bishop takes b6 as many of you are
pointing out after knight takes g3 if we take the knight and black is chilling but can we move the
bishop away with tempo essentially resulting in a double attack and i'm kind of guiding you toward
the right move bishop d4 is very simple and you know this is the kind of move that you find
intuitively with enough tactical practice boring bland but utterly and completely winning because
we're going to win at least a minor piece or maybe even a rook and that's it we take on g3
and the greatest thing is that if black moves the rook then black loses the ability to castle
kingside and it's not only just because the queens are off the board our attack dissipates i mean we
have a million pieces left and i can almost guarantee you that unless our opponent resigns
which is likely the game is probably going to end in some sort of checkmate likely along the e-file
so we've reached our final destination which is d4 kind of fitting yeah so our opponent does
decide i see what what he's trying to do i think f6 is the idea trying to trap the bishop ingenious
and under different circumstances i think this would be the way to go but here i think we can
use tactics essentially to keep the bishop alive for long enough until we find a way to extricate
it so i love people's instincts here right there is a move that we have patiently refrained from
because it's been ineffective until now but now i think is the time for that move
and the the general reason why is that black's pawn structure is now the weakest it has been
for the whole game but now i think it's time to really step on the gas pedal but there is a more
specific reason this move is strong and and i'm talking here about the move d6 so there's a couple
of additional benefits to this move and one of them is that we get a monster square for one of
our pieces that square is good in and of itself but that square also allows us to win back actually
win the knight on h5 everybody should be aware of the move g4 here g4 is very strong were it not for
knight to f4 so wouldn't it be nice if we could cover the f4 square what could we do it with
well we could do it with the knight and that's why we push the d-pawn carving out a central square
the bishop can take d6 which is an annoying move because it covers c7 but now we play g4
and the knight is trapped the knight is trapped knight f4 knight takes f4 and the e-pawn is pinned
so black should move the king out of the way and yes black will win the bishop on h8 but we win
in return the knight and we are up a full rook in the resulting position which is an easy technical
win so we couldn't move the bishop out on its own because g7 was covered but what we could do
is use our other active pieces to win the knight on h5 which is ironically like the
piece that's restricting the bishop you have seven good job by our opponent by the way to
find a couple of good resources but it's not going to help so let's get down to business here
things that i notice we could take g6 it really doesn't matter i mean i'm not worried about gh
that's just a random corner pawn and actually that further weakens the light squares so the
russian schoolboy move here would be to identify these two minor pieces the bishop and the knight
what what can we say about them well first of all they're on the same file second of all they're
undefended thirdly you should notice that black's king on f7 is tremendously vulnerable so a nice
so a nice move here a sleek move would actually be to first bring the rook into d1 a lot of you
would be tempted by bishop c4 which might even be the best move but i like to play
in this kind of nifty classy way we bring the rook into the game and we are setting up all
sorts of shenanigans against these two minor pieces how are we going to put them into effect
we're going to bring the bishop out of the way and simultaneously that's going to create threats
against the black king so where can we go well actually i really like the look of h6 here
setting up a potential mating net why h6 well that pawn is like a free play in american football
where like we don't care if we lose it so we might as well use it while it's still alive and it might
actually uh end the game still alive what are we depriving the black king of well the g7 score
we're actually entombing the black king in the center and not allowing it as an escape hatch
to h6 now it's finally time for the move that perhaps you wanted to play earlier and that's
bishop c4 setting up the threat of a discovered check against the black king and now we end the
game with what very very simple tactic it's not the bishop that we end up winning it's actually
not even the knight well it might be the knight it's the rook which is also undefended that's
why we put the rook on d1 to set up this tactic knight takes f6 i hope my internet doesn't go out
that would be sad knight takes f6 and the game is over and what's hilarious is that if king e7 is
played which it is not only is the h6 pawn going to be alive for the rest of the game but it's
going to win the game for us and the simplest way to play you have 10 seconds you're starting to
panic get the pieces off the board right trade everything that'll greatly simplify your task
takes takes and now we're looking at these two pawns when you have a far advanced pawn in the
end game it can be a great weakness in the middle game but a great asset in the end game because
that pawn is a future queen bishop g8 is a slam dunk move winning h7 then we step away with our
bishop promote the pawn and win the game yeah that's it i think resignation is uh imminent
and our opponent resigns gg 29 moves but a lot happened in those 29 moves
okay let's have a look 1750 is what we end up with yeah definitely i could go down the theoretical
rabbit hole here but i will give you the sort of general summary without bogging ourselves down to
too much into the weeds because again we'll have plenty of time to talk more about the theory
so knight c6 and d4 and the first branching off point is is here after the trade so our opponent
played the main move which is d5 very common at like a 12 1300 level is the move e6 and as a
little bit of inspiration i want to start by showing you my my like one of my shortest games
shortest tournament is a classical game and against a 1757 i was rated 1873 13 moves i
exaggerated slightly but but still maybe it was a very one-sided game that illustrates the
the danger of playing this line with black and the power of white's well-developed pieces
so this was in vegas a tournament that i played many many years in a row
my opponent was jeff shorter i gave this game in my um naroditsky method series so some of you
will probably be familiar with it and as you can see we got this position now you should
take my next moves with a grain of salt because the best move in this position according to the
engine the move that i'll talk more about is the immediate d5 just immediately striking at the
center instead i i took a slower approach i played knight f3 which is fine it keeps an advantage but
i try to give you the objectively best options knight f6 by my opponent knight c3 and here
believe it or not a decisive mistake by black the only way to essentially stay alive was to play
well either bishop e4 or d5 here i was planning e5 and this is a great version of an advanced
french because now the bishop is locked on c8 and in the advanced french you're not supposed
to give the white knight the c3 developing square so white is much better here but the game would
have continued bishop e7 is one of those automatic developing moves now which shows in sort of an
unfamiliarity with with white's main idea here and before my opponent knew it he's losing dead
lost in two more moves so what does white do based on what you already know about this position
yeah very good d5 d5 this is much stronger than e5 which yields the d5 square and black is able
to halt the progress of white's pawns d5 is much stronger my opponent trades doesn't change
anything and d6 simply ends the game if the bishop drops back there's queen e2 check and the game is
over black has to make the pathetic bishop e7 and the rest you can figure out on your own my opponent
tried one trick takes a knight c2 check but i could not care less about that rook because the
bishop comes out pre-move rookie one and that's it black's king is is utterly 94 was tried but
rookie one is my response not even taking the knight like preparing to take it with a rook and
it's made like in a thousand different ways here and he resigned it almost looks like black barely
made any moves in this game and yet that's just what happens when you don't develop accurately
don't develop accurately and you don't grab the center with your pawns so that was like a nice
inspiring game that inspired me to continue playing the alaban in terms of actual opening theory and
let me confirm this with stockfish 15 but i'm pretty sure that this still stands the best move
here knight f3 is second best but d5 is even stronger and it's it's similar idea to the game
um not not quite as clear cut so if black takes it we take back and the knight essentially is
nowhere good to go if black plays knight to e5 then now we finally develop our pieces we just
go knight c3 there's a million ways for black to lose the game quickly if knight f6 we actually
push d6 here it's a very scary looking move because you might be afraid to lose your d6 pawn
but if black tries to pick it off with his queen the knight comes in just in time and knight c7 is
a devastating threat black has to move the king out of the way of the fork king d8 now we bring
our bishop into the game attacking the queen and the line that i looked at is queen a5 check bishop
drops back and after the queen moves back only square is b6 uh incredibly strong here is a
ridiculous computer move lovely computer move a3 this is one of those freaking moves that shows
you who's boss what the heck is the idea well who can figure it out what is the idea of this
moon the idea is actually twofold which is kind of cool first of all we need to talk about bishop
takes d6 second of all and we'll start with this we should talk about a6 what's the idea of a3
e3 yeah very good we return to e3 and after queen a5 we now have the move before the queen
is simply trapped black has to give it away and if the queen goes the other way then it's attacked
by the rook it cannot catch a break check and this is uh just totally totally crushing
if black plays bishop takes d6 the second idea of a3 comes into play here we take
a6 and it may seem like bishop a5 check wins the queen but not just yet black has king e7
and now we drop back to b4 so the square itself the fact that it's protected now
is important we either put the bishop or the pawn on b4 and in both cases win black's queen
thank you joking giant knight really cool idea i love these quiet moves but what i love about them
is that you can understand exactly why they're played after the lines are displayed but it's
hard to figure it out if if you don't know this idea to begin with a3 is is just amazing and it's
the best move it's not you know no no dispute about that so the top engine move is actually
bishop check here trying to develop a tempo we cover with the knight and here again 95 is likely
and we just bring the other knight out to f3 trying to get rid of getting rid of black's
only active piece d6 drops uh the bishop this is a common allopan idea so remember it
but if black takes it then we take with the queen and we just have a tremendous position here we've
got this monster pawn on d5 and we've got you know fantastic development for our pieces for
instance bishop d3 castles castles d6 it looks like black is sort of out of the woods but he's
not i mean the pin against the knight is deadly the bishop's aiming at h7 the queen's pressuring
the knight black still hasn't completed their development and this is just a complete and
total disaster it's around plus two according to the engine and that's if black plays perfectly
so you can dig around here on your own suffice it to say that d5 the position is pretty easy
to play as long as you know to push the pawn to d6 with the knight having already come out to c3
all right so that's the rundown of e6 at a lower level you often see the move knight to f6
and as i hinted at uh during the game here again you go d5 and a great illustration of why you have
to push pawns in the opening is this line where white plays f4 forcing the knight back another
pawn move forces the other knight back and just look at how disastrous this position is black
literally cannot move and there's a really lovely line after d6 black tries to establish some sort
some sort of presence in the end game another ridiculous cracked out computer idea watch this
e6 now this just looks like a flat-out blunder f takes e6 d6 bishop e6 and you might say oh there
is a fork but no f5 is unprotected that's not the idea the idea is to follow up with h4
threatening h5 no problem the knight will move except it can't move it has nowhere to go after
h5 and if black halts the progress of the pawn then the knight is unprotected which means we
could bring the bishop out developing with tempo if black defends with the king then we have a fork
if black goes to bishop f7 then suddenly the bishop misdirects to b5 and we win the queen
so just the energy in white's position here is is amazing so another line torn to shreds
um and last thing i'll point out is is the move d6 also very common at sort of the you know
beginner to intermediate level and again you go d5 and here it's it's a little bit less
clear-cut after f4 but still the black's position is horrendous absolutely horrendous and the one
thing you should remember is that if black tries to fianchetto the bishop with g6 you can actually
prevent this and who can spot a move that again violates the general opening principle but makes
perfect sense now that you're aware of how dangerous the progress of the epon can be
yeah queen d4 is automatic either forcing f6 or in the event of knight f65 losing the game on the
spot uh for black knight h5 e6 and then always there's a check at the end because d7 is covered
and black loses everything here not just a piece but also the rook in the corner
so yeah this is why knight c6 is not a good move our opponent plays d5 trade and knight f3 now
there are many many lines here that i could talk i could talk about this for an hour all i will
mention here is the bishop takes f3 line which i'll show in a moment this is sort of the main
takeaway because here it's important to recognize that if you turn on the engine it will give you a
misleading assessment you need to keep the engine on at a high depth to figure out the best
continuation so here it's important to listen carefully the only other move here that occurs
frequently is e5 white responds with knight c3 and black pins the knight with bishop to b4
this is nothing to be afraid of we just go bishop d2 ending the pin renewing the threat against the
queen and essentially forcing the trade and getting the bishop pair right this is just a better
position for white because the bishop aims at g7 and if black plays e4 then we dive forward to e5
and this is considered to be slightly better for white there is nothing insane here white is
slightly better because of the bishop pair and you know pawn on e4 can be weak i think 97 is the main
line then the queen delivers a check and actually the new recommendation in the chess level course
i think is queen to b4 here aiming at the knight and preventing black from castling short you can
keep analyzing this on your own uh you can find this in the in the chess of course that recently
came out on the allopen but white's pieces are coming out at a furious tempo so e5 is not you
know a big problem but a common line and finally the last part of our opening overview before we
get to the game is bishop takes f3 which you will definitely meet if you play the allopen often
so here the best move is to recapture with the pawn now this looks like a flat-out blunder because
well that's the whole point of black's move black takes d4 and now you do something absolutely
crazy this is impossible to find if you aren't aware of it beforehand you trade queens looks
like total self-sabotage and now not only do you not defend c2 you play this move knight to b5
yeah very good i see a couple of you are familiar with this line not entirely i know this is pretty
well known by this point and i can check if there are any games there are a lot of games yeah there
is over a hundred games here so this is a well-known line and it's been well known ever since
1959 believe it or not it was first played so it's it's not exactly a novelty and this is
just incredibly problematic for black so what's going on here well first thing we should notice
is that knight c2 check allows white to carry out his main idea king d1 knight takes a1 obviously we
counter fork the rook on a8 and you might say and this is actually the most popular continuation
among humans knight takes a8 and now most people here with black play a move like e6 and you might
say well black's gonna go around and win white's knight and white's probably gonna win black's
knight and white's just gonna be down upon but it's not that simple because you can use your
bishops to prevent black's king from making it to b8 you give one check and after king c8 very
important move bishop out to f4 preventing king b8 and opening up an escape route for the knight
although you don't need to go knight c7 you're already winning here a 2390 walked into this with
black in 2007 he played g5 trying to deflect the bishop obviously white stays on the diagonal
bishop g3 this is a novelty by the way for some reason white played bishop takes g5 in the game
but bishop g3 is ending bishop g7 king moves out of the way attacking the knight if the knight moves
the knight is pinned in one and if black comes to the rescue then the winning line is rugby one
attacking the bishop forcing it back and once the bishop moves back another check on c1 and at this
point we switch from trying to win the knight to trying to win the king the king is now under a
checkmating attack just look at how white's pieces have gathered even the knight can participate in
the attack and i'll leave it up to you to finish this off but it's already totally totally winning
it's plus seven so this is just one of many important lines here the only other line that
i'll give for now is e5 right black and try to prevent the white bishop from moving out to f4
the thing is e5 leaves this diagonal open and we immediately exploit it and again the king just
cannot make its way to b8 and here i think f4 is best undermining the pawn then bringing the bishop
out and on the next move we just play king to d2 and the knight on a1 is lost but more importantly
after bishop b7 another beautiful detail can anybody spot white's best move in this position
and it's obviously it's not to take the knight because then black is finally out of the woods
again we generate chances against black's king all of a sudden yeah rook c1 threatening bishop c5
and preparing knight c7 so if black takes check then we grab and then we grab on a1 and we win
the game we're up a piece so that's how you punish e6 and e5 there is a lot more theory even in this
position but this video is going to go on forever and something tells me we're going to get this
again and the whole philosophy of the speedrun is that i give you the theory in sort of bite-sized
chunks and ultimately there will be videos dedicated to theory so it's not like you know
we'll never revisit this again but as i always say you're more than welcome to set this up
on a chess.com leechess engine whatever uh and and just analyze on your own look up the games and
you can learn a lot that way you don't just have to rely on what i tell you i'm trying to give you
the main stuff but you can carry the analysis forward on your own in any case after a knight
to b5 black can also take on b5 but the king here is under just tremendous fire a rook is coming to
d1 and black's lack of development absolutely kills him so for instance here here then we bring
the bishop out and it's literally mate in three because rook c1 is unstoppable and this is also
bodum's mate so plenty of lines like this i think the best move for black is to drop back to e6 and
now we play quick f4 f5 and the line goes on but we will revisit this at a later point in the game
our opponent did none of that and essentially gave us exactly what we wanted right away rook queen a5
d5 and i already think that black is is just in huge huge trouble i don't know what black should
do if black plays 95 then we give this check on b5 to essentially force the knight out of e5 and
this is just crushing again good position to sort of dig around and on your own remember that rook
d8 here is very strongly met with bishop d2 unpinning the pawn and setting up the x-ray
according to the engine black actually had to give away the exchange and this was the only way
to somewhat stay alive although here i think a very good move for white would be to essentially
force the queen trade with with queen to b3 and in the resulting end game white is not up that
much material it's an exchange for a pawn but if you look at the queen side pawns they can be
targeted with bishop b5 black is just way too underdeveloped here this is just totally crushing
in any case this is all very very depressing for black very sad same with long castle we can play
bishop to d2 and it's all the same stuff right i mean the queen is is under pressure the knight
is hanging and if black plays 95 then we could just go after black's king with a move like knight
b5 and the game is over the queen is hanging takes takes hits the bishop simultaneously
and if the queen moves then we can use the compromised position of black's king to unpin
our queen with check and then grab the knight and win the game straightforward this is all very very
simple lines i mean because black is just black has no pieces in the game so our opponent took
the knight we decided to take back with a queen although as i had mentioned gf is also worth
exploring um 95 and i actually really like our move queen g3 just keeping the queen out of the
range of black's minor pieces just to reiterate why didn't i go here right why didn't i play
a tempo well i did play a tempo move but it's because the move g6 here which is the only way
for black to deploy the bishop now comes with tempo and this line which i was attracted to
initially isn't as effective as i thought it was i thought maybe d6 uh is is interesting
it's a sexy move but i don't think it's i don't think it's as good as it looks
obviously the idea is to take the knight and win black's queen but black's queen can move
and this is what you have to be so careful about right because you have to make sure you're not
actually helping black get their pieces out here suddenly black clusters around in the center
and is maybe even able to trade queens on the next move with queen e6 so you've cashed in your
chips too early and this is a good example of one move itis right playing for one move threats
rather than for the larger attack which is what you have to try to do in these positions
okay so instead we decided on a more measured approach queen to g3
we have some questions if the knight had gone to d4 instead of e5
asks wind waver and you had gone queen e4 was there knight b3 oh this is a great question
because knight b3 is a cool trick right the queen x-rays the rook so yes there would be knight b3
but i think the simplest way to win this with white would probably actually be to take the knight
and sacrifice the exchange and then deliver a check and then castle kingside and you should
just sense intuitively the black is dead here because the king is just toast it's not that
the queen gets trapped the queen can move out of the way but now we go d6 and open up an attack
on b7 and the king is surrounded totally surrounded 800 different ways this is a position that you
should sense right you should really feel why this is totally lost and perhaps knight f6 is
more resilient but now the engine suggests uh to go to b4 in order to cut off the only escape square
available to black's queen this is nothing to be afraid of because the pawn pushes forward
intercepting the bishop then we bring our bishop out and trap the queen and we also it's just
checkmate a hundred different ways so i can you know expand on this but likely we would have just
taken b3 and you know developed our pieces and checkmate to the king but a great a great find
that that would be a cool defensive idea okay so knight d7 bishop d2 knight f6 bishop d3 again
we're playing simple slow straightforward chess refraining from automatic moves this was a great
find by our opponent a very ingenious defensive resource and a lot of people would have fallen
for this the way to avoid falling for this is just to double check right we played bishop d2
in order to threaten ip5 and even though this move doesn't look like it defends you always have to
give your opponent the benefit of the doubt and you have to say well let me look a little bit more
deeply and make sure that this 1700 and miss in fact missed a you know an obvious one move threat
sometimes it's actually too good to be true but you shouldn't trust your opponent out of hand right
you should play the move if you don't see anything against it but you shouldn't play it too quickly
there's a balance in any case we went bishop d3 we castled all of our moves were just incredibly
simple g6 and bishop e3 i think is the cherry on top obviously this hastens black's defeat because
after this we can stop our analysis the game is over we win a piece or the rook um more resilient
would have been to move the queen where could black have moved it well black could have taken
b2 but this position looks totally lost to me um because the knight can actually now go to b5
attacking the queen. I mean, that's a discovered attack. Probably, I would have played with black
the move queen to d8. And the game is not over. Like, if you look at the engine, it's actually,
black is able, I think, to force his way to castling. But an interesting approach here,
one that I had envisioned during the game, would be to play a move like knight to e4.
And in the event of the trade, now we can finally play the move d6. And essentially,
we're shifting the focus of the attack from the king, which we're also attacking,
to the b7 pawn. We're cashing in our chips. And yes, black in castle, congratulations.
But after bishop takes b7, we can win the game, for instance, with d, e, and then the simple bishop
f4 opening up a double attack on the queen and the rook. Black is castled, the king is safe,
but he loses material. And this is a more advanced attacking concept that we'll explore
in future videos more carefully, but we didn't need to use it here. The idea that there's a
focus of the attack, and usually it's to mate the king, but you have to be flexible, right?
Sometimes you have to allow your opponent, let's say, to escape, but only at the cost of a decisive
amount of material. Winning material can be a successful outcome of an attack, as it is here,
right? So it's not just checkmate that wins the game. It can also just be winning all of your
opponent's pieces. That's why I think knight e4 is such a strong move. Bishop g7, by the way,
there is a check on d6, and bishop b6 wins the queen. So looks like king f8 was the most resilient,
but now we grab another pawn, and white should be able to convert this pretty straightforwardly.
So you can continue to, you know, educate yourself on these lines. Queen d6, I was planning bishop
f4. Ultimately, our opponent was unable to withstand the pressure and missed bishop d4,
after which the rest I leave sort of up to you. We made some nice moves to convert efficiently,
but everything I did subsequently is very, very straightforward. Just remember the concept of
pushing a pawn and then creating the square that the pawn vacated for the knight, as we did here.
Pushing the pawn and then creating the square for the knight is also a positional concept that
you see pretty often. There's a lot more stuff I could talk about, but it's, you know,
for those watching on YouTube, it's almost four. Got a long day, so I'm going to call it here.
Hopefully, you found the analysis sufficiently illuminating. Again, a lot more I can always say,
but at some point, you got to draw the line, and I'm going to head to bed. So
hope everyone enjoyed the game and the analysis. This was pretty opening heavy, but once we
played d5, I mean, I would say that practically speaking, the game ended. It didn't end here,
but the position was unsalvageable from a human perspective on move 8, which again demonstrates
the power of knowing your openings, right? You just make chess a much more fun game,
and even if you mess up subsequently, messing up in a winning position is different from messing
up in an equal position. You're still increasing the likelihood that you're going to win more games,
and openings are crucial. They make chess more fun, and they make you a nightmare to deal with,
and the Aleppine is a total nightmare to deal with as we display it again in this game. Thanks,
everybody. I'm going to call it a night, and I'll see you tomorrow. Thanks, everybody. Bye.
threatening knight c7 and protecting the bishop and